uh you said on twitter a lot of people
it went viral that the boys album is
better than kendrick's album that's me i
listen to the boy album and guess what
music is subjective exactly
no it is it is like at the end of the
day
nobody can talk [ __ ] about someone's
opinion exactly if that's your opinion
see but most people that gave their
opinion on my opinion didn't listen to
the album they just gave their opinion
based off of kendricks oh [ __ ] like all
kinds of go don't don't say that about
kendra all right did you listen to it no
you ain't listening to it because if you
listen to it you'll see what i'm saying
because i listen to the boy [ __ ]
one through eleven whatever number it is
and i listen to his [ __ ] one through
eleven i got more vibes off of more
songs on this album than this one you
can't tell me i i you know you can't
change that in my head
literally yeah you can't and you can't
just go throwing his album in front of
people after five years like he's just a
messiah rap like like that's just
realistic especially when you got [ __ ]
like the homies and [ __ ] dropping [ __ ]
back to back all heat no skips like you
know what i'm saying
i'm not feeling did you like the
kindergarten at all
i listened to the whole tape
one song was like you know i'm saying
okay i see what the world right you know
i'm saying two songs the one with kodak
it was like all right you gotta know
that you put a [ __ ] like a real
[ __ ] a couple of other ones just like
two like
like
you know what i'm saying like
barber shop
oh [ __ ] vibe like you know i'm saying
like boogie joint like you know i'm
saying like like
like it's that sit at the barbershop
politic music and
picnics with the family and let me put
on my headphones and do my homework i
don't want nobody some people need that
though i'm not saying it's wrong right
right but you can't just say that's
better because the message he pushing
i still gotta deliver it a certain way
i think i think like
by the way the boys project is very
slept on not being talked about enough
shout out to the whole bay shout out to
vallejo
um but i just think like
in terms of
people got to stop taking uh music
opinions personal bro like if i feel a
certain way no because if i don't say
[ __ ] like this then people will just be
in the matrix
they just gonna be like oh they said
this is hot
so this is hot
oh well this is cool they just gonna go
with it like the everyday program how
they wake up and go to work every day
cut on the radio it's a program so
if a [ __ ] like me don't say something
the program continues like you get what
i'm saying
i gotta say so without the program you
get what i'm saying
people [ __ ] with me without the
independent push the labels and [ __ ] so
if people [ __ ] me that mean i gotta say
so so when i say something like i listen
to this tape and this tape too this one
was better people be like
man he's man [ __ ] that why that [ __ ]
say that you know i said if i was nobody
[ __ ] just should be like
sweeping under right
but since like oh this [ __ ] making
noise he dropping [ __ ] back to back
why he say that why he not a part of the
program it's kendrick turner he dropping
you know what i'm saying why we it's
time to push kendrick
like no bro she was cool you know what
i'm saying it well he's not weak
his his
his his the way he used words is good
right but that doesn't mean it's
appealing to everybody like that i don't
mean this to you yeah sonic it's it's
definitely a an album that if someone
told me sonically it's not for them i
can't even be mad at you i'm like yo i
haven't been in i didn't been in
probably
30 rooms
with over 20 people
and nobody downloaded it so you're not
going to put out this perception like he
just broke the internet but his music
streams you know what i'm saying that's
what i mean by i love the album but it's
good but yeah it's i you're not finna be
like he's the messiah rap it's been five
years that album was the savior right
right right no
who's in a month nobody's gonna be
talking about
none of them songs right
now
i might be slapping some of that [ __ ]
off the boy [ __ ] like in traffic just
getting money like in a couple months
because i'll be off some [ __ ] boy i'll
be on that [ __ ] i'll be trying to get
that bag you understand it just devised
to get off and [ __ ] rolling up what
smoke camp man i'm saying they get past
me
we roll [ __ ] like you know
[ __ ] like